Nigerian spaghetti is hands down my
favorite pasta dish ever with such
unique and rich flavors everybody is so
delightful let's get into it first
things first we're going to saute half
an onion to its fragrant from there
we're going to come with one cup of
peppers and give that a nice mix then
we're gonna add some tomato paste and
break it down fully next we're gonna add
crushed tomatoes Stir It Up put the lid
on it and let it cook for 15 minutes in
the meantime you guys should know by now
always start your pasta water and cook
until done now what truly says Nigerian
spaghetti apart is its unique flavors
from the richness of the ginger to the
spice from the Cayenne it is so amazing
from there add your pasta give it a nice
toss folks here are some parsley because
of fancy you have to try this out you
will love it